Okay, let's continue exploring server-client setup as we look at working with ShotGrid.
Now, before we get too far into where ShotGrid fits among the three pillars of our collaborative
production pipeline and workflows, I want to talk about ShotGrid as a possible source
control solution.
So, ShotGrid, formerly Shotgun, is a product from Autodesk that can also work as a version
control solution in place of Perforce.
ShotGrid tool integration is available in Unreal Engine, but only when the ShotGrid plugin
is enabled.
ShotGrid Toolkit configuration is project-centric.
It's set up much the same way a Maya project file is organized and then stored on a server
where it can be accessed from that storage location.
This pipeline maintains that same Maya-type project structure and then uses ShotGrid
as a project management system in order to maintain and manage those assets inside that
single Toolkit project configuration.
While this is a viable alternative solution for version control, there are some other
considerations that must be made before choosing ShotGrid as your version control solution.
First up, ShotGrid Toolkit is a pipeline toolkit based on the ShotGrid platform.
It does make this easier to install or write custom tools for studio integration, and
Epic Games does implement that feature function as part of how we utilize ShotGrid.
Toolkit is a file-based system.
It does help you organize where things are stored on disk so that everything is nicely
structured based on that familiar Maya project structure, which is a structure that is probably
very familiar for most of your creative team members.
Toolkit is an assistant.
It does not try to take over or abstract the data in your pipeline, but instead it
is there to provide artists with tools that are designed to make finding your information
easier for your team, and hopefully that'll help avoid making mistakes during production.
Toolkit is mostly used to help you share your work by storing all of its publishes
in ShotGrid, making it easy to share updates and work as it moves through the production.
One thing to be aware of is that ShotGrid as version control has an inherent danger
when Toolkit is used for this purpose.
ShotGrid as version control can break fairly easily if you aren't careful.
Any artist can gain direct access to the main project file storage location if they
know the file path.
Directly accessing the project files instead of going through the proper steps of accessing
using ShotGrid tool integrations in DCC applications will overwrite that stored information
and will potentially break the file path.
This is not true version control, as it's left to the artist to ensure that the files
are versioned when saved.
Overall, ShotGrid is not as robust a version control solution as Perforce, but it does
have other important uses.
If we stick with Perforce as our source control solution, the next step in our production
workflow is going to be production management.
Since we've been talking about ShotGrid, that is actually what ShotGrid's purpose
will be in our collaborative production pipeline, and that's how Epic Games utilizes ShotGrid
in production.
As artists build assets, they can submit them to the Perforce Depot for other artists
in different departments to work on in real time.
ShotGrid is how Epic Games handles our production management for asset tracking and
assignment using a media importer to add turntable renders, screenshots, color guides,
or any completed step in the asset creation process.
Artists can upload the asset media to ShotGrid, and Epic Games uses a customized LaunchBox
Python tool that we created expressly for the submission of dailies and media assets.
After the creative team members upload the asset media to ShotGrid, the production management
team then maintains organization, reviews work, leaves or manages notations, and begins
the next steps in our collaborative review process.
ShotGrid for production management allows for project planning, asset tracking, media
management, and more.
At Epic Games, we use ShotGrid to manage our own internal projects on Fortnite, Fortnite
Cinematics, and other related games in the Fortnite Metaverse.
One thing to note is that the UCE project that you see pictured here in this slide
to the right is still in the early stages of development and will soon be updated
to match the Epic Games production format.
That's all for this section.
In our next section, we will explore version control in Unreal Engine.